North Korea denies it treated otto
warmbier cruelly while he was imprisoned
in the country in an article published
this morning North Korea's state news
agency claimed he was not tortured
warmbier died less than a week after his
release thousands of people attended the
University of Virginia students funeral
yesterday the 22 year old was buried in
his hometown of Wyoming Ohio Michelle
Miller is there Michelle good morning
good morning this cemetery sadly is the
last stop on otto warmbier long journey
home from North Korea it was not the
fate his family had hoped for when he
was arrested and imprisoned some 17
months ago but they do take comfort in
knowing that he did come home and that
he is now at peace a bagpiper led the
funeral procession out of Wyoming High
School where otto warmbier graduated
just four years earlier as the her
stroke to the cemetery mourners lined
the street standing shoulder to shoulder
Ohio senator Rob Portman was with warm
beers parents last Tuesday we was flown
back to the u.s. in a coma this college
kid never should have been detained in
the first place
what a warm beer is dead because of
North Korea there's no question about it
so many people showed up for the service
more than two thousand that a hundred
had to be turned away the capacity crowd
filled the school auditorium and spilled
over into the gym and cafeteria it just
doesn't feel real yet honestly warm
beers girlfriend Alex begoña's said he
made the fun times more fun and the hard
times less difficult warm beer sister
Greta and brother Austin also gave
eulogies
I've known awesome for a long time Jay
Klein is Austin warm beers good friend
he felt overshadowed and same with the
sister by his brother with how amazing
of a student he was athlete that sort of
thing said before Austin got to high
school there's already high expectations
for him based on how well his brother
had done a monitor played this video of
warm beer throwing snowballs in North
Korea his belongings from that trip were
on display and the funeral program
quoted this line from his high school
graduation speech this is our season
finale this is the end of one great show
but just the beginning to hundreds of
new stamps this service was conducted by
a rabbi who would travel to Israel with
OTO a few years ago he said he relished
rediscovering his Jewish roots after the
funeral the family welcomed all of the
mourners back to their home they were
just very excited to know that all these
people had such respect for their son
Nora respect is right and the family has
handled this with such grace Martine you
think they're going to